let me step back to neural networks for
for another brief
minute you wrote parallel distributed
processing books that explored ideas of
neural networks in the 1980s
together with a few folks but the books
you wrote with the david
uh ronald hart who is the first author
on the back propagation paper which you
have hinton
so these are just some figures at the
time that were thinking about these big
ideas
uh what are some memorable moments of
discovery and beautiful ideas from those
early days
i'm going to start
sort of with my own
process in the
mid 70s
and then into the late 70s
when
i met jeff hinson and uh he came to san
diego
and we were all together
um
in
my time in graduate school as i've
already described to you i had this sort
of feeling of
okay i'm really interested in human
cognition but
this disembodied sort of way of thinking
about it that i'm getting from the
current
mode of thought about it is isn't
working fully for me
and
when i
got my assistant professorship i went to
ucsd and um
that was in 1974.
something amazing had just happened dave
rummelhart had written a book together
with another man named don norman
and the book was called explorations in
cognition
and it was
a series of chapters exploring
interesting questions about cognition
but in a completely sort of
abstract you know non-biological kind of
way and i'm saying gee this is amazing
i'm coming to this community where
people can get together and feel like
they've collectively exploring
you know ideas and um
it was a book that had a lot of
i don't know lightness to it and you
know
the the don norman who was
the the more senior figurative roman
heart at that time who led that project
you know cre always created this spirit
of playful exploration of ideas
and so i'm like wow this is great
but
i was also
you know still trying to get from
the neurons to the
to the cognition
and
i realized at one point i i got this
opportunity to go to a conference where
i heard a talk by a man named james
anderson
who was an engineer
but
by then a professor in a psychology
department who had used
linear algebra to create neural network
models of perception and categorization
and memory and i
just
blew me out of the water that one could
you know create a model
that was simulating neurons not
just
kind of
engaged in a stepwise
algorithmic process that was construed
abstractly but it was
simulating remembering and recalling and
um
recognizing the prior occurrence of a
stimulus or something like that so for
me this was
a bridge between the mind and the brain
and i just like start and i
i remember i was walking across campus
one day in 1977 and i
almost felt like saint paul on the road
to damascus i said to myself you know if
i think about the mind
in terms of a neural network it will
help me answer the questions about the
mind that i'm trying to answer
and that really excited me
so
i think that a lot of people were
becoming excited about that and one of
those people
was jim anderson who i had mentioned
another one was steve grossberg who had
been
writing about neural networks since the
60s
and jeff hinton was yet another and
his phd dissertation showed up uh in an
applicant pool
to a post-doctoral training program
that dave
and don
the two men i mentioned before remember
heart and norman
were administering and rommelhardt got
really excited about hinton's phd
dissertation
and so
uh hinton was one of the first
people who came and joined this group of
postdoctoral scholars
that was funded by this this wonderful
grant that they got
another one who is also well known in
neural network circus
circles is pulse milenski he was another
one of that group
anyway
um
jeff and jim anderson organized a
conference at ucsd
uh where we we were and uh it was called
parallel models of associative memory
and it brought all the people together
who had been thinking about these kinds
of ideas
in
1979 or 1980 and
this
this began
to kind of
really resonate with some of rommel
hart's
own thinking some of his reasons for
wanting something other than the kinds
of computation he'd been doing so far
you